die mega liebe zwischen queen elizabeth
und prinz philip
sie wehrte unglaubliche 73 jahre eine
liebe für die ewigkeit eine liebe wie
aus dem märchen
es war einmal ein armeeoffizier und die
reichste prinzessin der welt sie ist 13
er ist 18 sie ist reich er ist zwar in
prinz aber philipp hat am tag des
kennenlernens nur sechs fund auf dem
konto aber es ist liebe auf den ersten
blick der 23 juli 1939 kurz vor dem
zweiten weltkrieg
marien college daten auf der junge
offiziersanwärter führt die prinzessin
durch die schule
elisabeth ist sofort fasziniert von
philipp ein blonder athlet mit tatsachen
und blaue uniform
er ist exxon dritten grades mit königs
blut nach dem treffen schreiben sie sich
briefe
erst nach dem krieg kommen die jungen
verliebten sich näher am 11 august 1946
auf dem schottischen schloss balmoral
passiert ist er kniet vor ihr nieder und
bittet um ihre hand die green schwärmt
später so von dem moment es ist
wunderbar einfach zauberhaft ich legte
meine arme um seinen hals und küsste ihn
während er mich an sich drückte und in
die luft hob doch philipp hat es im
britischen königshaus zunächst nicht
leicht seine deutschen wurzeln nach dem
weltkrieg ein problem
keiner mag den deutschen typen nur
elisabeth philipp hat kein geld für
einen verlobungsring doch die
traumhochzeit findet trotzdem statt am
20 november 1947 westminster abbey
sie ist 21 er 26
er ist ein playboy hatte affären sie
wird königin von großbritannien
nordirland und ist immer nur auf
gemeinsam bekommen sie vier kinder aber
73 jahre lang machen sie in getrennten
schlafzimmern auf dennoch ist es die
love story des jahrhunderts elizabeth
und philip sind ein eingeschworenes und
eingespieltes team
beide können sich stets gegenseitig
aufeinander verlassen krisen meistern
sie gemeinsam die wichtigste frage
hinter den geschlossenen schloss türen
ist für die queen immer was denkt philip
prinz philip er ist ihr ging gemäss
protokoll immer zwei schritte hinter ihr
oder neben mir eine offizielle
regierungsfunktion hat er nicht liest er
ein geheimes starts dokument aber die
queen trifft keine wichtigen
entscheidungen ohne ihn philipp ist
immer ihr kritischer und wichtigster
ratgeber und ihr größter halt er war
ganz einfach meine stärke und mein
felsen all diese jahre wir alle schulden
ihm mehr dank als er jemals verlangen
würde oder wir jemals wissen werden
bewegende worte der queen an ihrem 50
dem goldenen hochzeitstag über ihren
ehemann prinz philip und queen elizabeth
beide werden mit über 90 jahren zusammen
geimpft auf schloss windsor
die beiden genießen jeden moment und es
war liebe bis zum letzten blick
vergangenen freitag stirbt prinz philip
im alter von 99 jahren großbritannien
gedenkt mit salutschüssen und
schweigeminuten dem verstorbenen ehemann
von queen elizabeth die jahrhundert
liebe der beiden royals sie wird
bestehen auch über den tod hinaus
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren